good afternoon
everyone my name is researcher miller
and the scp we're going to be studying
today
is scp-2912 object class
neutralized special containment
procedures
the remains of scp-2912-1 2 and 3
are to remain preserved within
individual cryogenic storage units at
biological containment
site 66 and the following
are archived special containment
procedures
scp-2912 are to be held in isolation
with an
individual humanoid containment units at
biological containment site
66 scp-2912 instances
must be fed a strict diet of circus
peanuts
and sugar water that has been
artificially colored
purple foundation physicians are to
remain on standby
despite knowledge of scp-2912 health and
biology
being extremely limited at this time
scp-2912 designates three roughly
humanoid organisms resembling typical
circus clowns scp-2912-1
scp-2912-2 and scp-2912-3
genetically close to human all instances
sharing a
relatively recent common ancestor in
homo sapiens
scp-2912 entities have or had
undergone severe and very corporeal and
physiological
augmentations all contained instances of
scp-2912
were abruptly neutralized on november 16
1998. the incident determined to be
entirely accidental
with blame placed on poi 4569's
failure to communicate relevant
information to foundation personnel
the following are brief overviews on the
scp-2912
entities scp-2912-1 overview
an almost entirely spherical body
a complete lack of a skeletal system
while its legs arms and head did exist
they were found to be vestigial and
heavily atrophied
closely resembling an air-filled balloon
scp-2912-1 was able to transport itself
through the air via an internal gas
bladder
created from the left lung so grossly
enlarged
that it occupied the majority of
internal space
and a modified anal sphincter
black and white skin forming horizontal
stripes
around its body capable of extending a
long black tongue the act
producing a vocalization similar to the
sound produced by
party horns although its level of
intelligence could not be ascertained
it was at least capable of understanding
several english words
mostly in the form of commands
scp-2912-2 overview
and unusually tall 2.56 meters and
spindly
with the exception of its left hand and
abdomen which both appear bloated
human organism capable of producing
music from its asymmetrically and
disjointed body
vertebra are comparatively large and
oddly shaped
producing a sound similar to a xylophone
in use
with songs appearing to differ in
correlation with the present
angle of scp-2912's spine
how it was able to create these sounds
without directly striking
individual vertebrae was never deduced
the left hand was large and flat and
used to strike its bloated abdomen
the resulting sound is similar to those
produced by bass drums
its face lacked eyes and had a bulbous
red nose
capable of honking despite being
entirely organic
and was primarily dominated by a large
mouth
devoid of lips yellow skin
covered in red polka dots
vocalizations failed to correspond with
any known musical instrument
but has been described by the foundation
musicologists
as resembling an accordion crossed with
an andes
martinaut apologies for the
pronunciation i've never seen that
before
potentially higher intelligence than
other scp-2912 entities
as it was able to compose unique music
when commanded to do so
music produced by scp-2912-2
triggered strong emotional responses
among listeners
it remains unknown whether this reaction
was anomalous
or simply an explainable psychological
response
scp-2912-a overview
resembled a biological human more
closely than scp-2912-1
or scp-2912-2 the appearance of face
paint
is part of its natural appearance
laughter was apparently its only form
of vocalization this noise
represented a cognito hazard and
triggered uncontrollable laughter
among its listeners lasting for 6 to 32
hours an ability to create cream pies
seemingly out of thin air it is
speculated that nearby matter was
transmuted
and teleported to scp-2912-3
in the form of cream pies
these anomalies were discovered on
october 5th 1998 after a raid on a
fairground
that had hosted herman fuller's circus
of the disquieting
only minutes before the arrival of
foundation operatives
one small tent was left behind
the others having vanished as operatives
approached
inside were scp-2912-1-2-3
and p-o-i-4569
the following is interview poi 4569
please explain what you were doing prior
to your apprehension
listen fuck-face i don't go to your job
and pull the anomalous [ __ ] out of your
ass
i got work to do and mr fuller ain't
exactly the most patient bloke
so you're a member of herman fuller's
circus of the disquieting
yeah what's it to you what is your
profession
clown breeder excuse me
you death i'm a [ __ ] clown
breeder
how exactly does one become
a clown breeder my father was a clown
breeder
my father's father was a clown breeder
my father's father's father
well he was a horse beer and what does
this job
actually entail you that [ __ ] stupid
it's in the goddamn name
enlighten me i
breed clowns
i see is this an old profession
you mentioned your father and your
grandfather
in the real old days he didn't have
enough breeders
back then the best we had was child
practice
child breakers what
you think all freaks are just born that
way body does a lot of growing when
young
just got to help it along a certain path
course back then you could only make a
hunchback
nah they deserve more pretty i mean the
laughing man
turtle boy hell the inside out girl
that was done the old way as you say
i think that's all we need at the moment
thank you for your time
[ __ ] you on november 16
1998 all scp-2912 entities
self-terminated between zero four
hundred hours
and zero six hundred hours video
revealed no
changes in behavior prior to the
neutralization event
when scp-2912 instances abruptly
exploded
their containment units coated in blood
viscera
confetti and viscous black liquid of
uncertain purpose
when confronted about this incident poi
4569 stated
verbatim you [ __ ] shit-eaters
forgot to milk the clowns didn't you
way to ruin a decade of work
you [ __ ] well i never thought i'd read
that out
addendum an incident occurred on
december 25th 1998
when a video surveillance within poi
4569
cell showed the door opening while
external video depicted the door
as closed and no alarm was triggered
during this time
the faint sound of calliope music became
audible within the cell
and poi 4569 proceeds to converse with
an unidentified
individual the following is a recording
of this incident
[Music]
bad time you got here is that smile or
frown i could never tell were you
[Music]
a liar billy
come on i'm the best [ __ ] clown
brittany you got
and mr fuller knows it
the unidentified individual then briefly
entered the cell
they appear muscular but further details
are obscured by a cloud of
what appears to be smoke which permeates
the cell
via the anomalous doorway poi 4569 cried
for help
but security personnel were unable to
reach him in time
an autopsy revealed that his cause of
death was acute myocardial infarction
more commonly known as a heart attack
okay that about does it for our lecture
today
thank you very much for listening you
are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to andre
bashirt thank you very much andre
your pledge is very much appreciated if
you would like to know how you can get a
personalized thank you at the end of
each of my videos
as well as some other really cool stuff
as well go to patreon.com
forward slash the vulcan thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you